[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire sur chose aujourd'hui mais
dit emmanuel djadi pour son coming out
ou petit montparnasse tu le pianiste
gaspard dehaene qui sort un album
consacré à chopin chez mille et une
notes et qui donnera un récital à la
salle gaveau le 9 février est notre
troisième invité ayant attrapé le vide
on terminera l'émission par une surprise
une rediffusion mais une surprise mais
commençons en images par notre époque
voici celle que vous avez choisi pour la
symboliser on commence pas la vôtre ou
plutôt les vôtres gaspard dehaene
expliquez-nous ça c'est la première c ou
alors c'est à la cité des congrès à
nantes dans le cadre du festival de la
folle journée dont je reviens en fait la
folle journée qui a lieu tous les ans
qui est un le plus gros festival de
musique classique au monde peut-être
qu'ils brassent une quantité de deux
personnes vous pouvez le voir alors jeu
là il me semble que c'etait en 2019 donc
il ya pour le coc vise justement
recevait tous des petites notification
un virus était un bon brlas et donc au
jour de fête à lacets
2007 il va perdre de poids et là c'est
aujourd'hui et c'est aujourd'hui mais il
faut saluer vraiment le tour de force à
la fois du public et évidemment de
l'équipe qui s'appelle le créa donc qui
s'occupe de l'organisation et de rené
martin qui est le directeur artistique
puisque ce qu'on sait enfin ce festival
a brassé énormément de monde juste avec
une organisation folle des masques pour
tous évidemment mais le la vraie
découverte c'était le plaisir qu'ont les
gens à revenir au concert ils n'ont pas
aimé les
les vidéos en fait pendant les
confinements c'est sûr ils m'ont guérie
quelque chose et on voit ça fait bien ça
fait je sais pas si ça leur fera bizarre
quand on va revenir comme ça ça nous
fera probablement bizarre
dans l'adaptation la vôtre médiévaux
noël
la voici ok ce que s'est passé c'est
toutes ces images qu'on reçoit sur les
différents groupes whatsapp ou autres
qu'on peut trouver sur internet j'ai
même pas réussi à trouver d'où elles
provenaient vraiment mais je trouve
qu'elle est assez symptomatique de notre
époque et je me mets vraiment parfois la
place de de 7 personnes sur le fauteuil
où on a plein de bonnes intentions fait
on veut faire un peu des révolutions et
des hashtag est pourtant dans notre
quotidien mais voilà on a des des
crevettes qui viennent du bout du monde
nos écrans viennent aussi d'endroits où
il ya des périodes où il ya parfois des
conflits et je me dis bah voila moi
j'essaie de dem évertué à
servir le bien commun autour de moi déjà
et d'essayer d'avoir un peu plus d est
prise de conscience active plutôt que à
coups de hache tags il ya aussi du
cannabis aussi mais ça doit être du cbd
et bien commençons
[Musique]
mehdi emmanuel déjà dit on vous a vu
dans boîte noire avec pierre niney dans
la prière de cédric kahn dans je suis à
vous tout de suite de baya kasmi pour
lequel vous avez fait partie des
révélations des césars en 2016 vous êtes
maintenant au petit montparnasse les
mardis et mercredis dans coming out un
one man show dans lequel vous racontez
votre conversion musulmans de naissance
vous êtes devenu catholique je me
souviens que tomer sisley à ses débuts
raconté qu'il était juif et musulman
ça n'était pas vrai c'était juste pour
faire rire vous c'est vrai vous êtes
vraiment un converti c'est ça je sais
vraiment emmanuel doux et manuel qui a
été le choix de deuxième prénom l'église
me proposait de choisir un prénom j'ai
gardé mes dix même a dit certains appels
et les glaces avant le d voilà mais j'ai
rajouté emmanuel pour la fiche même si
voilà quotidiennement m'appelle mais dit
ouais vous dites que vous avez failli
mettre michel mais ça donne et mehdi
ziadi mitchell et parce qu'un accord ait
pas été d'accord oui enfin si il avait
rien à dire un fait lui même c'est pas
son vrai nom
les humoristes parle beaucoup de
religions depuis quelques années mais
vous en parler vraiment presque en excl
en expert est presque en théologien ça
vous intéresse vraiment ça a vraiment
été une quête
une quête quasi obsessionnelle moi
depuis toujours j'ai eu 7 cette quête de
la vérité
donc oui j'ai baigné dans une famille
musulmane de tradition musulmane j'en
étais très heureux mais il ya eu un
moment donné cette envie de d'un
ailleurs d'aller cette curiosité qui m'a
mené bas sur un long chemin qui est
encore actuelle je veux dire on s'arrête
jamais de mai mais effectivement ça m'a
ça m'a plongé dans dans beaucoup de
d'idéologie et de spiritualité que j'ai
que j'ai rencontré et et aussi beaucoup
de rencontres de personnes avec des
parcours très différents alors ce que
vous racontez sur la scène c'est que
vous avez d'abord été musulman puis
protestants puis escrocs comedia mais il
sera là
comédien puis catholique et enfin
humoriste et à chaque fois il sait il
s'agit d' y croit très fort au fond que
l'on soit escrocs ou
protestants ou catholiques aux comédiens
ce qu'il faut c'est y croire c'est
croire c'est croire après la petite
différence qui avec la fois c'est que
moi je m'attendais pas à avoir ce coup
de foudre cette révélation mystique avec
avec jésus après bien sûr le fait d'y
croire bah forcément comme j ai dans le
spectacle je reprends saint-augustin dis
je je crois pour comprendre et je
comprends pour croire c'est un peu le
résumé de toutes ces erreurs mais en
même temps il faut quand même avoir une
prédisposition vous raconter très bien
comment vous rentrez dans un temple
protestant un moment est au tout début
comme ça par curiosité croyez que c'est
une secte je vous confirme c'est une
secte mais une secte karoutchi voilà
vous êtes tout 17 ans les religions
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il ya
cahier vous dit est ce que vous avez
déjà entendu parler de jésus et vous
arrêter quoi mans m'a posé cette
question deux mille fois je me suis
jamais arrêté
d'ombré disposition il ya peut-être une
prédisposition en tout cas moi je
connaissais un jésus que celui de
l'islam
si sa quête un prophète mais mais ce
jésus donc parler ce pasteur qui
avait l'air lui aussi d'y croire dur
comme fer que parler d'un jésus qui
était presque à l'opposé de celui que je
connaissait c'est vrai que ça m'a ça
m'intrigue et donc j'ai voulu me faire
ma propre opinion et donc j'ai commencé
à lire les évangiles et effectivement le
jésus que j'ai découvert dans la bible
et dans les loges il était assez éloigné
de celui que je connaissait non l'islam
et alors vous justement qui vous êtes
vraiment intéressé à tout cela et qui
avaient cru quelle différence y entre
l'islam entre le protestantisme et le
catholicisme parce que pour les athées
tout ça c'est la même chose quelque
chose à voir différents des folklores
différents
vous
je dirais qu'il ya déjà beaucoup de
choses qui les rassemble beaucoup de
points de convergence et cette idée
d'une transcendance d'un dieu unique
c'est c'est la même chose pour les
musulmans que pour les chrétiens
protestants ont compris
après c'est vraiment sur la nature du
christ effectivement ou dans l'islam
c'est un prophète est dans l'oeil dans
le christianisme c'est vraiment
l'incarnation de dieu c'est le fils de
dieu c'est dieu sur terre d'eau emmanuel
emmanuel veut dire dieu avec nous c'est
pour moi la principale différence avec
avec l'islam donc c'est vraiment cette
nature de jésus ou dans l'islam les
considérer simplement comme un prophète
mais il ya l'idée de dieu dans le
protestantisme
c'est le fils de dieu mais il ya tous et
toutes ses différences avec la vierge
marie qui n'est pas la mère de dieu cas
probablement eu d'autres enfants et pour
les catholiques qui a cette idée dans
l'eucharistie notamment si cette
différence avec les protestants que
jésus est vraiment présent est réel dans
l'eucharistie et moi c'est ce que j'ai
vécu dans cette abbaye à septfonds c'est
vraiment j'ai ressenti sensiblement
cette présence d'amour qui m'a qui
m'envahit et ça on a beau il croire pas
y croire folklore pas folklore quand ça
vous arrive je suis pas le premier à qui
c'est arrivé dans l'histoire et
l'histoire je serais probablement pas
dernier donc à l'accord et ça ça vous
saisit comme comme quand vous tombez
amoureux de quelqu'un mais
en fait c'est un spectacle qui aussi
contre la prédétermination certaine
manière on peut choisir fond vous êtes
né musulman la plupart des gens se
contente de ça ils choisissent la
religion de leurs parents comme on prend
comme on dit mon autobus je prescris pas
qu'ils passent devant chez nous
au fond vous vous montrez que on peut
choisir ouais c'est vraiment le
spectacle est vraiment cet appel à
l'anti déterminisme mais aussi qui est
une vraie richesse de ce que nous
apporte notre pays la france on a la
chance de choisir sa religion ou pas
dessus mettra t on peut même être athée
c'est pas le cas partout aux états unis
si vous êtes athée ouais c'est ça ne
marche pas et en afghanistan si vous
êtes chrétien c'est dur aussi donc ça
y'a papa tu en viens à remet ça va oui
voilà mais mais mais ce que veut dire
par là c'est que effectivement on a la
chance d'être dans un pays qui nous
garantisse est cette liberté de choix
cette liberté de conscience on peut
choisir d'assumer sa sexualité d'assumer
de 2e et ça c'est propre à chacun on a
un héritage on a ce qu'on a reçu et puis
on a cette possibilité de choisir
d'aller vers un ailleurs soit de revenir
à ce qu'on a reçus mais mais ces sept
décès ont aussi déterminé c'est cette
liberté qui met kim heger en même temps
est ce que c'est de la spiritualité est
ce que ce sont des révélations
successives ou est-ce que ça réflexe
consommateurs c'est à dire au fond est
pas content de ce qu'on a on se dit la
côte et voir s'ils sont plus indulgents
si ça peut être le risque ça peut être
le risque de se dire mais d'ailleurs
c'est une des tendances de notre société
ont bu sin un peu il ya aussi des
nouveaux courants spirituels où on
mélange un peu de yoga un peu de
spiritualité hindoue et puis un fond
peut-être chrétiens parce que j'ai
allumé un cierge on fait un peu notre
supermarché c'est vrai que là la
nouvelle religion peut dire l'occident
c'est un peu c'est un peu celle ci après
moi c'est il ya vraiment eu cette
rencontre ça je peux pas le nier je suis
très libre dans tout ce que je fais
notamment par rapport à l'institution de
l'église je peux être très critique
vis-à-vis de l'institution et des dogmes
je respecte les dogues mais
l'institution je peux je peux avoir des
choses à redire donc je garde cette
liberté et en même temps bien sûr que je
peux butiner dans toutes les
spiritualités je pense qu'il ya du bon
dans nos plein de choses et c'est ce que
redit le concile vatican ii il ya
vraiment des semences de vérité non dans
beaucoup de choses dans la nature dans
les autres spiritualité vous êtes
croyants oui je suis je suis catholique
et alors je l'étais moi ce moment c'est
un peu un exemple de tout ce dont vous
je ne parlais je l'étais d'abord par
éducation et d'ailleurs franchement je
maintenant que j'y suis revenu j'en suis
très heureux parce que les bornes vous
harry baur comme disait oui bah c'est
aussi que je me suis marié en début de
dt les stations et merci beaucoup avec
manuela donc aussi un projet avec vous
voilà et et en fait on a tous les deux
beaucoup parlé de le plaindre de plein
de sujets évidemment des religions c'est
difficile de faire l'impasse aujourd'hui
et nous dans la beauce qui nous a
profondément marqué c'est la préparation
au mariage et cette idée justement de
transcender et je me souviens d'une
phrase qu'on et qui nous a tous les deux
beaucoup plus et qui est assez
illustratrice de padduc du match dans la
religion catholique et dans les autres
d'ailleurs c'est qu'on ne se marie pas
parce qu'on s'aime nom se marie pour
s'aimer autrement dit c'est maintenant
que ça commence et c'est maintenant que
voilà que lors d'autres parlent de
chemin de croix aussi à voilà mais c'est
cette idée d'amour dans le aussi dans
une forme de souffrance dans une force
de doubler de soi et est en fait tu
découvres voilà une richesse
effectivement je pense pas que tu me
considère à la partage quand on voit
votre parcours enfin l'idée que vous en
donnez là on se dit mais comment est ce
qu'il a fait pour en faire un spectacle
humoristique
parce que c'est pas gagné au départ à
part la partie où vous êtes escrocs et
très bonne escrocs d'ailleurs vous savez
de sortie opus enfin bientôt et mais
sinon on se dit mais où est ce qui va
nous faire rire bah en fait ça je dois
rendre à césar ce qui appartient à césar
se rendent à mon co auteur ce qui lui
appartient thibault evrard que si mon
metteur en scène qui apporte est
vraiment cette finesse dans l'écriture
c'est d'être tout le temps sur cette
ligne de crête où on peut à la fois dire
des choses assez profonde mais avec avec
légèreté autodérision et immo parce
qu'effectivement on touche des sujets
notamment sur les extrêmes puisque je
peux être très dur envers les extrêmes
qu'ils soient chrétiens musulmans ou
athées puisque les représenter oui il ya
un progressisme qui ne tolère que
lui-même convoi avec pas très tolérant
avec les les croyants et donc l'idée
c'était vraiment de de pouvoir dire des
choses en essayant de ne blesser
personne
et d'ailleurs on a même adapté parfois
l'écriture quand on a un couple de juifs
ou un musulman ou autre qui est venu
nous dire ah là j'ai vraiment été
blessées m'a parfois en prenant en
compte vous allez on vous dit alors
aujourd'hui mais on a quand même il ya
maintenant une forme d'unanimité où on
essaye de faire en sorte qu'on puisse
dire des choses je pense que l'art est
aussi là parfois pour nous questionner
c'est pour ça que le mot one man show on
a eu du mal un peu avec on parlait
vraiment seul en scène ce que one man
show c'est vraiment une écriture un gag
à rire que du divertissement mais des
gens qui sortent de la salle très ému
parfois en larmes donc voilà c'est
vraiment une comédie dramatique mais
vous nous emmener sur des terrains où
les humoristes n'ont pas coutume de nous
emmener en plus on se retrouve avec vous
faire une retraite dans une abbaye avec
des moines
effectivement vous devez être le seul à
peu près sur la scène française
aujourd'hui avoir eu ce type
d'expérience ouais ouais mais c'est pour
ça que moi il y avait quand j'ai voulu
écrire ce spectacle c'était un sentiment
d'urgence artistique je savais que
j'allais faire notamment du tort à ma
famille qui sont peut-être plus laïque
que moi parce que pour eux la religion
c'est vraiment privé on n'en parle pas
et je leur ai fait beaucoup de mal avec
la conversion et et d'en faire un
spectacle c'est comme si j'avais
enfoncer le clou son mauvais jeu de mots
donc ça a été très très dur pour eux
mais il y avait vraiment cette urgence
artistique je me disais mais en fait on
a besoin dans une période où il ya ça se
communautarise beaucoup d'apporter un
peu de liant de d'essayer de créer des
ponts plutôt que de mettre des murs et
de dire bah voila moi tous ces
personnages les ai rencontrés tous ces
gens vivent en france et on veut plutôt
vivre en paix et et ça fonctionne plutôt
bien quand on regarde un peu près ce qui
n'est pas le cas effectivement partout
dans le monde et c'était aussi un peu
faire la promotion de ça et dire bah oui
on peut aller au théâtre juste pour
rigoler mais on peut aussi aller au
théâtre pour se rencontrer et moi quand
je vois dans une même salle à rabin avec
parce que c'est vraiment été le cas dans
ma salle à côté d'une femme voilée est
une fille aux cheveux bleus tatoué
j'imagine donc qu'elle était vegan et
athée probablement jamais dit à peu
d'endroits où ces gens se retrouvent et
puces après en ce montant même échanger
et ça pour moi c'est une des richesses
du spectacle mais il faudrait pas non
plus oublier
aussi d'autres chapelles qui vous avez
fréquenté vous avez fait le
conservatoire d'art dramatique en suisse
vous avez travaillé dans le théâtre
public en tant que comédien vous êtes
maintenant dans le cinéma français ce
sont des chapelles aussi woods seul avec
leur petit leurs habitudes leur
idéologie
leur prière leur miracle
la leur leurs extrêmes par endroits
la même et c'est pour ça que je suis
vraiment au carrefour de ce ménage à
trois c'est vrai que je suis dans ce
milieu qui est parfois très anticlérical
très très dur cas beaucoup d'à priori
sur les chrétiens parfois à raison
qu'ils ont parfois été même blessé par
par l'église ou par des gens d'église et
le fait déjà de me rencontrer il ya déjà
un a priori qui tourne parce que je
viens pas de versailles et j'ai pas les
pommettes roses donc déjà et un a priori
qui tombait puis après c'est vraiment
dans la rencontre alors parfois ça passe
mal effectivement ça va fermer des
portes même dans ce milieu justement
très tolérant je crois d'ailleurs que
j'ai eu plus de problèmes dans ce milieu
de problèmes de racisme ou quoi dans ce
milieu que dans tout autre milieu pas si
tolérant il est là de le dire c'est là
où ça peut être nous c'est intéressant
c'est parfois dans la rencontre une fois
qu'on a dépassé un peu tous les sujets
un peu clivant quand on est dans la
rencontre là effectivement il ya des
vrais il ya des vraies amitiés qui
peuvent qui peuvent naître et j'ai envie
que sur quasiment chaque projet que j'ai
alors parfois c'est pas du tout un sujet
et puis voilà mais quand ça arrive sur
le sur la table parce qu'on parle du
spectacle des projets ça a pu donner
lieu à des belles amitiés même si en
apparence on est très éloigné dans nos
façons de penser et de vivre ça vous a
offert à chaque fois on a la pression
que vous soyez
musulmans protestants
escrocs ou
comédiens à chaque fois et catholique
enfin pour avoir l'impression de changer
d'amis et vous changez de livres au fond
vous allez passer de du coran que vous
aurez parker quand vous êtes enfant à
aux évangiles et puis aux trois soeurs
de tchekhov est rien au fond vous
changer aussi d'amis
mais en même temps certains restes de
ses amitiés là
aujourd'hui il ya vraiment une unité
parce que l'ordi voilà je suis marié je
vis ma vie de comédien ma vie est
beaucoup moins rocambolesque que quand
je faisais d'escroquerie de banque
j'ai une vie beaucoup plus je regarde
des séries netflix comme tout le monde
soit en entrant donc j'ai une vie
effectivement moins en moins - an quand
mme baulès mais j'ai gardé ça va vous
faire marrer un peu les escroqueries
convoi dans le cinéma français que ce
n'est pas une qui tient debout oui voilà
on arrive un peu à voir là où c'est
crédible les passes elle est rarement
oui oui c'est vrai que sauf quand c'est
vraiment inspiré de faits réels mais
effectivement j'ai la chance d'avoir pu
garder quelques amis j'en ai perdu
beaucoup mais j'ai la chance d'avoir
gardé des amis dans chacun des dépôts
pour garder parce que voulez vous
inciter la tue vous le dit souvent ça
vous a coûté à la fois dans votre
famille à la fois parmi vos habits
qu'est ce qu'on vous reproche à changer
de changer de religion
ça déstabilise les autres et je dis
pourquoi je me dis pourquoi moi je m'en
contente ouais je pense qu'il ya ça
renvoie parfois c'est cette liberté à ce
choix de la liberté on
certains n'ont pas compris plutôt des
gens qui avec qui j'ai grandi qui était
qui était musulman comme moi qui n'ont
pas compris après c'est simplement la
vie qui fait en sorte qu'on prend chacun
au chemin et voilà mes mais ceux pour
qui il ya eu vraiment une hostilité
c'est ce peut-être à qui ça les renvoyer
à des choses trop difficile pour eux il
ya aussi la pression sociale est aussi
que dans l'islam dans un certain islam
notamment un islam rigoriste l'apostasié
est passible de peine de mort pas
l'oublier il ya c'est passible de peine
de mort dans les pays encore aujourd'hui
donc il ya aussi ce fonds là dans tous
sympas dans tous bien bien bien
heureusement mais parfois au maroc ces
déchéances de nationalité votre mariage
est annulé enfin dire y avait quand même
une mort sociale qu'on peut pas
accompagner d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
j'ai appelé ce spectacle coming out
parce que je me sentais très proche
d'eux aussi des amis homosexuels qui
quand ils font leur coming out il ya des
menaces parfois parfois du rejet de
l'incompréhension et moi c'était un peu
cette idée là c'est à dire bah oui le
fait d'affirmer une identité spirituelle
il peut y avoir soin de
l'incompréhension quand c'est quelqu'un
de progressistes qui ne comprend pas
soit du rejet des menaces pour d'autres
mais l'idée c'est bas de discuter encore
une fois de se rencontrer ce que vous
appelez les progressistes c'est ceux qui
ne croient en rien ouais ou qui croient
en eux je ne sais pas si on ne croit en
rien parce que même de ne pas croire en
rien c'est une croyance
autrefois il croyait au progrès mais ce
n'est même plus le cas c'est plus qu'un
aujourd'hui son il fera peut-être une
forme de nihilisme aujourd'hui c'est un
catastrophisme ya presque un messianisme
avant on avait peur de la fin du monde
aujourd'hui l'écologie devient parfois
pour certains fin il ya une sorte de
nihilisme où c'est la fin de tout et et
il ya plus beaucoup d'espoir et plus
beaucoup d'espérance où ça devient une
religion alors moi qui n'ai aucune gêne
à passer moi je vais t'en savoir des
religions partout j'ai l'impression que
d'autres comme le parti communiste par
l'otan était une religion séculière mais
une religion j'ai l'impression que
l'écologie peut en être humain choisi et
la laïcité pour certains on est une
différence de ce cross ce que croit vos
parents la laïcité française n'exclut
pas qu'on accuse parler de religion il
ya aucun problème tous les droits c'est
l'état qui est laïc c'est pas les
instituts c'est donc la licité c'est
devenu de religion pour certains et ses
terres et ses relations et est-ce que
vous avez pas ce sentiment vous qui est
religieux est profondément oui je vous
en avais plus et plusieurs des
religieuses c'est vrai et là où ce jour
j'en sais que dans l'étymologie même du
mot religion ça veut dire relier relie
les gens entrent effectivement on est
dans une société où il ya à la fois un
individualisme très fort est en même
temps besoin d'appartenance très fort et
et c'est sûr sûr exagéré que les réseaux
sociaux notamment on se crée des
communautés je parle à ma communauté et
donc il ya effectivement des multitudes
de religion pour moi le seul critère
valable c'est est ce que c'est une
religion qui nous enferment peu importe
le parti communiste le progressiste
en tout cas c'est chacun qu'il créait
cet enfermement non voilà où mais oui
mais ça peut aussi être dans un an quand
vous êtes qu'avec dans un autre soi
quand vous êtes avec lui des gens qui
pensent comme vous ça ne vous sort pas
de vous même et ça vous emmène pas vers
l'autre et peut-être que moi la seule
chose que je trouve intéressant en tout
cas dans la foi chrétienne
après ça peut être transposé sur
d'autres croyances c'est c'est quand ça
vous sort pour aller vers l'autre pour
moi c'est un des seuls l'une des seules
choses qu'on doit regarder si ça vous
enferme ça vous ça ne fait que vous
caresser dans le sens du poil examen
l'impression que vos petits combats sont
les combats de l'humanité j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on est dans l'action sa
région un peu l'image de tout à l'heure
c'est on agit à coude hashtag on pense
que tout le monde est contre nous aidons
conso on s'est fait dans l'action fait
dans la rencontre faut être dans
l'espérance
qu'à moi ceux qui sont autour de moi est
la religion dans laquelle je suis c'est
ce qu'on sait ce que j'essaie de prôner
en tout cas ce que j'essaye de vivre à
savoir bas
aller vers dieu c'est aller vers l'autre
et s'est trouvé dieu dans le regard de
l'autre qu'ils soient athées ou musulman
ou que ça c'est quoi votre vie
catholique aujourd'hui il n'ya plus les
prières tant de fois par jour non c'est
et enfant via quoi qu'est ce que ça nous
astreint à quoi bah c'est vraiment déjà
effectivement il ya les rites donc à la
messe dominicale il ya le fait de la
chance à temps c'est seulement le
dimanche seuls mendiant tous les matins
effectivement mais c'est là aussi c'est
la liberté vous choisissez ce que ce que
ce que vous voulez moi j'essaye de faire
l'angélus tous les midis et c'est
vraiment dans le concret des choses
c'est vraiment cette idée de la charité
c'est quelque chose qui m'est qui m'est
très cher c'est vraiment mon prochain
mon prochain mais même mon voisin quand
vous dites c'est quoi être catholique
typiquement quand noël dernier avec mon
épouse on a fait des sables et on allait
donner le soir de noël des sablés à nos
voisins parfois qu'on connaissait pas
parfois qui était seul et ça a donné
lieu à des rencontres et pour moi être
catholique c'est simplement ça alors
après oui il ya toutes les questions du
deuil mais tous moi ce que je vis
aujourd'hui quand je dis que j'étais
musulman et qu'aujourd'hui chaque
catholique ça s'est accompli dans le
catholicisme j'ai parfois même certains
rites qui sont restés avant de faire
chaque action d'ailleurs je buvais un
verre d'eau jeudi bis mulder qui veut
simplement dire au nom de dieu eh ben je
garde cette chose là tout chrétien que
je suis j'aime rendre grâce à dieu quand
je mange avant de venir ici a vendu au
théâtre à cesser de mettre dieu c'est
d'être dans la contemplation
c'est pour ça que j'aime beaucoup le
pape françois et et d'heures saint
françois d'assise saint françois
d'assise qui était vraiment cette
contemplation de la nature dans cette
contemplation du monde de l'autre pour
ça que j'aime mon métier être comédien
c'est se plonger dans des histoires dans
le coeur de deux personnages se dire
mais qu'est ce qui l'a mené à sa caisse
quelle a été sa vie ça dit quelque chose
de dieu ou de l'absence de dieu et vos
enfants si vous en avez aussi vous en
avez un jour
voulez vous les ferez entrer dans une
religion à leur naissance ou vous
laisserez attendre je pense que
j'essaierai de leur transmettre ce que
ce en quoi je crois mais par contre je
veillerai vraiment à ce qu'il soit libre
vrai la liberté pour moi mais c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui m'est très
cher et donc je verrai ce qu'il soit
libre et qui choisissent que ce qu'ils
veulent et parce que moi ce que je
voudrais pour eux c'est donc coming out
c'est le mercredi et le jeudi mardi
mardi et mercredi pardon au théâtre du
petit montparnasse
même le new york times on a dit du bien
j'étais au festival d'avignon et on
demandait un peu les spectacles qui
sortait du lot et se trouve qu'avec un
sujet comme ça ça se resserre balladur
c'est sûr on fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après avec gaspard den
[Musique]
gaspard dehaene vous vous êtes pianiste
votre nouvel album est consacrée à
frédéric chopin vous serez mercredi
prochain le 9 février à la salle gaveau
en récital vous vous n'avez pas
abandonner l'islam pour le capitalisme
et vous avez abandonné le tennis qui est
pourtant bien classé pour la musique
classique c'est ce que raconte le clip
où vous interprétez valse des dieux
propose de regarder tout de suite un
extrait
[Musique]
je
on
[Musique]
2 et
alors c'est vraiment choquant je crois
que qui vous a révélé votre vocation
musicale vous aviez 16 ans à l'époque
mais est-ce que ça s'est passé sur un
court de tennis non quand même pas mais
effectivement chopin est l'élément
déclencheur du tournant de ma vie
puisqu'avant donc j'avais une passion
d'enfance avec toute la folie que ça
implique
pour le tennis et je reprends ma m'a
fait découvrir donc la passion de ma vie
qui est aujourd'hui voilà que j'exerce
depuis donc mes 16 ans
professionnellement donc la musique et
le piano et au début je n'ai commencé
que par interpréter chopin
évidemment ensuite très vite j'ai
découvert le reste et j'y suis revenu
donc là il y a deux ans parce que
j'avais vraiment envie de me replonger
intégralement seul avec chopin mais il
ya une spiritualité d'ailleurs votre
amour de chopin comme comme celle qui a
pu écrire si on veut il dire lesquelles
je me suis reconnu dans beaucoup de ces
paroles et notamment dans le désir de
s'élever le désir constant de s'élever
la musique permet cela puisque la
musique et l'art le plus l'art par
excellence à mon avis puisqu'il est
celui qui nous prive de la parole et
celui qui quelque part nous nous fournit
autre chose que l'on ne peut même pas
expliqué juste ressentir et quand on est
interprète on doit rendre cette star un
petit peu plus technique que ça et quand
même comme la cuisine on doit bien
savoir à un moment quel est l'ingrédient
qui est voilà et les personnes qui goûte
s'ils ne se rendent pas forcément compte
mais il trouve ça bon et est donc mon
métier consiste aussi parfois à traduire
en en dosage en élan en questionnement
et finalement j'ai beau passer mes
journées à cela c'est un questionnement
perpétuel donc c'est aussi un peu de
l'ordre de là la vérité aussi dans l'âme
il y aurait la vérité j'ai l'impression
que ça c'est quelque chose qui est très
présent la musique classique y aurait la
vérité d'une interprétation d'un morceau
qui a été composée par quelqu'un qui
n'est plus là pour nous dire quoi que ce
soit l'un de la vérité en musique c'est
qu'elle est fugace une aussitôt est elle
apparue qu'elle a disparu et le problème
c'est que si on essaye de la rattraper
c'est à dire de lui redonner vie on a
perdu quelque chose qu'on a perdu la
fraîcheur on a perdu la spontanéité donc
il implique d'être toujours voilà c'est
une histoire de présence au moment où
l'on joue et il faut le travail consiste
non pas à appuyer sur les bonnes touches
mais à appuyer sur la bonne touche
évidemment et à faire en sorte que cette
chimie du moment se passe au concert au
disque de pour un ami dans un salon
métiers manuels vous chantez beaucoup
dans votre spectacle très bien
d'ailleurs aussi bien des psaumes que du
rap mais vous faisiez une grande marque
tout à l'heure à à gaspard avant
l'émission commence le fait qu'ils
jouent toujours mineur c'est ça
ces remarques et soeurs en écoutant
peut-être que j'avais cette
prédisposition le soir vous écouter mais
peut-être que voilà tu as été à attirer
dans dans une certaine un certain
romantisme
plutôt plutôt sombre plus tôt alors les
musiques mineurs effectivement les on
caricature un peu en disant qu'elles
sont soit triste soit révolté soit
nostalgique
chez schubert dont on donc qui a été
célébré la folle journée de nantes c'est
le spécialiste du minage joyeux du
minutes du mineur lumineux et du majeur
aussi qui finalement donne sa petite
pointe de tristesse donc là encore cela
prouve que le que la musique va au delà
des mots et que chacun aussi la ressent
avec sa pleine liberté sa pleine de
sensibilité
après c'est vrai que dans la musique
romantique qui est musique qui m'a
bouleversé donc depuis mes 16 ans il ya
beaucoup de morceaux en mineur et
notamment pour le piano il ya quelque
chose de très exaltant il est beaucoup
plus facile quelque part de s'exprimer
quand on a un interprète
de pas avec la tristesse avec la
souffrance que l'exprimé la joie c'est
la chose la plus simple la joie et
pourtant jouer une musique joyeuse et
arriver à communiquer cette joie au
public qui ne l'est peut-être pas
forcément
cc c'est le défi ultime pour tous les
instrumentistes mais vous y connaissez
bien quand même moi je n'ai jamais
remarqué que je termine heures non je ne
dirais pas que je viens mais sensible
peut-être a effectivement à la à la
beauté aux émotions que peuvent
provoquer la musique classique plus que
toute autre musique mais c'est vrai que
ces contournements de redire alors vous
avez consacré cet album à chopin vous
l'avez intitulé est la mesure c'est une
formule qui veut dire quoi une formule
de chopin exactement donc chopin a écrit
un rondo quand il était jeune donc à
rondot c'est un morceau qui un peu sur
le format des chansons finalement avec
un refrain qui revient et des couplets
et chopin cette formule à la masure mais
c'est un peu imposée d'elle même puisque
il y a une manière singulière dans la
musique de chopin qui fait qu'on la
reconnaît immédiatement on peut
l'interpréter de toutes sortes moi j'ai
choisi
de lire un petit peu la vie de chopin et
j'ai remarqué que chopin est né en
pologne comme vous l'entendez il a un
nom très polonais son père était
français et
et en fait il a vécu en france pour la
plupart du temps sauf les moments où il
voyageait la deuxième partie de sa vie
et il n'a cessé de composer la pologne
poser des polonaises des mazurkas
il écrivait dans ses lettres que ça son
pays lui manquait et les mazurkas ce
sont alors donc c'est une danse à trois
temps qui est l'anti valls en quelque
sorte là où la valse propose la danse de
salon avec les grandes robes d'un
certain confort une certaine tenue la
mazurka et des deux bords très très très
proches l'un de l'autre c'est pas compte
aujourd'hui vingt sept est totalement
révolutionnaire
est
alors dans un autre style en tout cas la
mazurka était beaucoup plus populaires
peut-être y avait eu aussi une idée de
groupe d'histoire voilà et et il ya ces
accents assez sauvage assez un imprévu
avec une forme de bd des coups de talon
au sol qui font résonner le plancher et
voilà et c'est une danse de la joie
alors eh bien il y en a plusieurs sortes
et il ya aussi donc celle de la
tristesse évidemment et chopin on a
composé 60 la première a été publié
alors qu'il venait de quitter la pologne
qui était à ce moment-là envahi par la
russie et j'ai vu une sorte en fait
c'est mazurka comme comme un journal
intime de l'exil est choquant qui est
composé des valses des balades des
études des préludes et nocturne pour
gagner sa vie et qui est composée des
mazurkas dans son coin pour s'adresser à
son peuple est d'ailleurs son collègue
donc le compositeur robert schuman
disait qu'elle était une musique à forte
résonance politique dont il vaudrait
mieux pour la russie qu'elle ne pénètre
pas en pologne ces pages parce qu'elle
elle générerait un engouement une
possible révolte populaire et donc ils
les ids s étaient des canons sous les
fleurs parce que sous leur apparence de
petites de miniatures de choses un petit
peu raffinés comme l'était chopin elle
avait une portée beaucoup plus grande
que cela la peau pour moi je passe c'est
vraiment l'introduction de la team dans
la musique
alors c'est la musique roma c'est le
romantisme bien entendu mais on n'en
quand on écoute chopin on entend bien
que toute la gamme des émotions intimes
va y passer de la tristesse au bonheur
du de l'espoir au désespoir
vous dites qu'au fond et c'est peut-être
ces musiques là qui vous intéresse le
plus en tout cas dans cet album il ya
une autre dimension beaucoup plus
exaltés en fait oui alors
c'est très vaste en effet l'un team trek
il était à l'époque qu'ils étaient
amis plus ou moins en tout cas
extrêmement respectée et mutuellement
avec livre compositeur franz liszt tout
à fait qui est l'anti chopin c'est à
dire là où chopin était intime liste
était exubérant était une véritable rock
star il était le piano de l'extérieur
alors chopin aimait jouer que devant des
publics de 5,6 personnes exactement qui
faisait la salle pleyel pour lui c'est
un cauchemar voilà un genre que lis
qu'on écouterait adoré sa vista fini a
fini à b voilà mais les deux les deux
ont eu un moment leur heure de gloire
très bref pour chopin qui est vite cessé
d'aimer la scène et liste un peu plus
longue des années il a quand même fait
plus d'un plus de 1000 concerts partout
en europe et mais à la fin il en a eu
marre des concerts probablement parce
qu'il aspirait à quelque chose d'encore
au dessus et il a il se sentait un peu
barde pas très sérieux en fait il il est
seul à lui renvoyer une mauvaise image
de lui même bon c'était voilà deux
personnes comme ça qu'ils ont des
exigences toujours plus élevés et il
faut dire que liszt il un jour décrit sa
journée il passait cinq six heures de
l'exercice il disait en même temps
chateaubriand balzac la bible il faisait
de l'exercice ans et n importe qu on se
demande si sa cote et les femmes
oui à mettre son
il a il a eu je ne sais combien de vies
cet homme il est fascinant mais donc
revenons à chopin comme vous le disait
très justement c'est le le piano de
l'infini dans dans le cercle le plus
intime possible quelque part et je dois
avouer que j'aime et plus grande joie de
seul au piano de solitude au piano sont
entièrement dédiée à chopin je me
souviens chez moi j'ai mes parents plus
exactement de pouvoir chez lesquels je
peux jouer jusqu'à 23h 20m après si je
venais pas de problèmes de voisinage
mais jouer comme ça a pu voir le temps
passer et et pour cause dans la musique
de chopin il y aussi un rapport au temps
qui nous permet quelque part de nous
rendre maître du temps et de de quitter
cet été cette sensation de la trotteuse
et des heures et des cardeurs aidés de
chiens retard et qu'est-ce que voilà et
tout à coup la en jouant on a prises une
prise directe avec le temps que l'on que
l'on des formes c'est un mélodiste
extraordinaire chopin même quelqu'un qui
n'aime pas la musique classique qui ne
la connaît pas voulu que vous faites pas
en tant que chopin il est subjugué c'est
le dernier quart de ce bourg lui arrive
pas à la cheville à noël bob gaz bois
est le bon a la bonne idée ou la
mauvaise idée de lui rendre hommage si
bêtes des paroles dessus mais oui mais
ils le rendent un hommage quand je crois
qu'il avait quand même évidemment une
il voulait absolument pas prendre le
dessus et ça il ya beaucoup de chansons
de rap aujourd'hui à qui commence par un
viseur de chopin ouais j'ai remarqué ça
et puis plus largement le classique et
je pense même aux jeunes compositeurs la
soutiennent pas même pas mal qui va de
c'est vrai que le piano et chopin
effectivement aux intro d'albums ou de
une chanson c'est la question que me
relaxer l'un des modes et finalement ça
mélodiste absolument incroyable et
est-ce qu'on peut rejouer indéfiniment
chopin les mêmes morceaux et être
toujours aussi est ému et bruit même
parfois par pas l'âme au lieu-dit par la
musique on est en train de jouer et bien
je serais tenter de vous répond
malheureusement par la négative parce
que en tant que professionnel il ya
toujours un moment où cécilia c'était
cette idée votre père un peu catholique
si j'ai pris du plaisir c'est suspect
aujourd'hui la raison de l'abondance
confession est en fait il ya tellement
de loi d'esthétique déséquilibre de de
timing de phrases et dago gic tout ça ce
sont des des mots que j'emploie exprès
pour me pour me crédibiliser
qui en fait voilà propose des lois et la
l'interprétation idéal sera celle qui
contentent ces lois et non le plaisir
amateur je le dis au sens positif du
terme de celui qui aime et notamment
chez chopin il ya un tel abandon
physique dans sa musique moi je sais que
souvent je joue des pièces comme ça que
j'ai pas joué depuis deux mois et j'y
prends plaisir or je sais que si je vais
les retravailler pour un concert ce qui
est le cas en ce moment je passe par des
phases où je déconstruis pour
reconstruire pour retrouver une
fraîcheur mais une fraîcheur qui soit
la v2 aussi de ce qui pourrait caractère
non amateurisme à mon amour de jouer
chopin pour répondre un peu plus
directement à votre question
quelque part mon travail consiste à
faire en sorte que la communion et lieu
et c'est là que je prends plaisir sans
culpabiliser m merci tous les deux
d'avoir participé à cette émission je
voulais dit le troisième invité attraper
le coc vide donc on va terminer mais
avec une surprise une rediffusion mais
une surprise même pour moi
[Musique]
et aciman alegria qui publie son second
roman chez flammarion le grand art dont
le héros est un commissaire priseur qui
a connu son heure de gloire mais
désormais proche de la retraite est un
peu dépassé le métier a beaucoup changé
non un commissaire priseur de ce début
de xxième siècle ça ne ressemble pas au
grand commissaire priseur de la fin du
xxème exactement c'est ce qui arrive aux
personnages peuvent y viennent c'est que
il ne reconnaît plus son propre métier
parce que ça a tellement changé en 10 15
ans avec l'arrivée d'internet et des
réseaux sociaux qu'il est complètement
largué il n'arrive pas à se réinventer
alors il y en a qui le font et lui il
comprend pas les enchères en ligne
comprend pas que y'a plus personne qui
vient ne comprends pas qu'on puisse
désirer et payé très cher un objet ou
une oeuvre qu'on n'a pas vu en vrai
voilà ce qui arrive aujourd'hui un ski
très secrètement on connaissait les
enchères par téléphone ça a toujours
existé mais les gens venaient voir les
oeuvres sur place avant de il venait
avant et les regards des anonymes ou non
et puis après ils ont serré c'est par
téléphone et maintenant c'est vrai que
le commerce de l'art en ligne est en
plein air en plein boom et que ce soit
par les réseaux sociaux ou par don au
point comme et ils 6 comme ça va oui
c'est vrai que alors on voit bonne
commissaire priseur il commence ce roman
en train de lire le journal et lui ce
qu'il est évidemment c'est la rubrique
nécrologique
dès qu'il ya des seuils à grandes poches
ou
alors c'est ce qu'ils disent et que pour
lui son fond de commerce c'est les 3 d
les dettes le divorce et le désert
c'était en fait dès qu'il ya dette dès
qu'un divorce dès qu'il ya des seuils a
chance où il ya possibilité d'une dalle
et dépouillé un appartement il appelle
sa dépouille et mais en réalité c'est
aussi le
second enfin une nouvelle vie tous ces
objets ne sont pas nés dans cette dans
cette famille là il existait avant dans
une autre famille dans une autre maison
et ils vont pas changer encore une fois
de maison et de famille les objets ne
meurt pas en même temps que leurs
propres yvois la longue dure beaucoup
plus longtemps que nous non mais c'est
vrai quand on y pense ils doivent
beaucoup plus réceptable il existera
bien apprendre
mais c'est moi il faut quand même le
réaliser en permanence les commissaires
priseurs ils savent ça
que nous sommes il ya plus éphémère que
ça alors suite à un enterrement en
toscane
alors c'est très drôle d'ailleurs parce
qu'il assistait à un enterrement et le
relais c'est le petit détail et au cours
de cet enterrement et ils voient que le
moral et c'est une très belle pendule
bien mise en évidence et en fait il
s'aperçoit après que c'était un coup de
génie mais c'est une très belle pendule
on se dit bon bah donc y ait un héritage
qui va être formidable et en fait non il
a mis là en évidence qui avait de mieux
pour un
attrapeur de notre ami co2 adaptant
commissaire n'attrape commissaire
priseur oui et comme il faisait ou bons
mollets il est mort donc on se dit
qu'avant quand il donnait des réceptions
et ben c'était un peu un objet éclatant
pour en mettre plein la vue et faire
croire qu'ils avaient les moyens d'avoir
une grande amie renée derrière ou plein
de choses effectivement mais en moins
dans cet héritage il va trouver un
mystérieux retable par un florentin
inconnu la datation ses débuts du xvème
siècle
mais ses antérieurs à la découverte à
l'invention de la perspective par bonnet
les skis on sait que bon élève qui a
inventé la perspective entre 415 et 425
quoi le premier à l'avoir utilisé ces
masaccio qui était très jeune et là le
tableau serait antérieure en face d'un
retable ce serait antérieur et l'a su ce
serait dingue ça se ferait évoluer ces
soirées dingue pour ceux qui sont
vraiment tatillon sur la santé ce serait
d'ailleurs
disent on ne sait pas non plus la grande
révolution mais c'est vrai que ce serait
énorme ça vous avec quelqu'un a fait un
tableau avec de la perspective avant
masaccio en occident oui oui mais on dit
que ça a été inventé par rené ce qui met
donc en dépression voilà on dit ça mais
en fait qu'est ce qu'on en sait pas ce
que c'est ce que j'explique dans le
roman brunious qui il a laissé aucun
écrit parce qu'il était très avare de
ses inventions et donc il avait très
peur de la concurrence y brûler tout est
donc on dit comme ça vasari un siècle
plus tard 10 et brunelleschi qu'il a
inventés mais ça arrange bien l'histoire
d'ériger un peu voler les skis en héros
en me disant je suis en train de
remettre en question du tout j'espère
bien le génie brunet veste
juste que en fait on n'en sait rien oui
mais alors si vous avez jusque là le
tableau vous avez montré on l'a
attribuée à caravage et avant cela on
l'avait attribué à quelqu'un d'autre ça
c'est mais ces voix là et c'est à peu
près le cas de la plupart des tableaux
de cette époque puisqu'ils ne sont pas
signés
bien c'est une des raisons pour les
axes de votre robe seco faut tout ça est
une histoire d'attribution on attribue
un tel c'est exactement mon propos est
ce qui m'a ce qui va inspirer ou ce qui
m'a ce qui a nourri mon imaginaire c'est
que quand on voit la joconde on se dit
ok on me dit que c'est un que c'est
léonard mais bon ce panneau de bois de
peuplier qui auraient traversé les alpes
à dos de mulet et il ya 500 ans je suis
pas sûr que ce soit exactement cela et
pas un autre c'est c'est juste on le dit
alors probablement mais c'est aussi
possible que non et sinon et bien d'où
il vient et quelle est son histoire etc
etc un peu sa vie face à se re table
dont il ya votre commissaire priseur il
ya aussi une jeune experte en art qui
doivent à eau qui vous ressemble un peu
des choses comme ça que je vais
maintenant je vous je vous connais elle
aussi elle va se demander qui est cette
hauteur et là ça devient une véritable
enquête c'est à dire que vous pouvez
date est assez précisément le bois et
vous savez que grosso modo c'est 14
105,14 115 on peut penser avoir peint
dessus et c'est très précis 1 et vous
commencez à regarder tous les peintres
alors elle elle dit ocz après 60 ans ont
peint très peu donc on va regarder ceux
qui sont nés à cette époque voilà l
époque les plus de 60 ans non c'est pas
la peine donc on regarde tout ce qu'ils
ont pu peindre ça peut pas être masaccio
étaient trop jeunes des terres aux ans
et pas lui donc on va chercher et elle
commence à chercher il devient obsédé
florence est évidemment et elle trouve
et et
et c'est ça qui est intéressant le
problème c'est que c'est plus à la mode
c'était que tout à coup autour de ce
commissaire prison jeudi mais attendez
vendre un même un type qui a
révolutionné l'art au début du xvème
siècle ça intéresse personne en ce
moment ils s'intéressent plus à des
planches de bandes dessinées les
nouveaux collectionneurs les nouveaux
collectionneurs ils connaissent pas la
peinture ils se sont démultipliés mais
ils connaissent pas la peinture il
s'intéresse à la bande dessinée donc une
planche originale berges et ça c'est bon
éventuellement des photos ça ils
comprennent mais art à bruxelles
encore une fois pas viviane et est un
peu à côté de la plaque ces boat au
héros
t il et il est encore une fois papa en
phase avec son temps et avec son époque
parce que pour lui ben il est devenu il
a une épiphanie devant cette oeuvre et
il veut prouver à tout le monde que
qu'il réussira à faire grimper la cote
d'un retable du quattrocento dont
effectivement plus personne ne
s'intéresse plus personne et c'est ça
qui veut faire et pour lui ça devient un
enjeu villa il a beau d'exemple ya le
fameux salvator mundi de léonard de
vinci qui a été vendu 450 millions de
dollars chez christie's alors qu'il est
hideuse on peut le dire je veux même pas
je l'aimé je
le trouve idiot y compris dans votre
roman est ravi de sa vie dans men et
j'avais vu en vrai il n'ya pas très
longtemps au louvre à l'exposition l'ena
il est absolument horrible et vous
expliquer d'ailleurs en tout cas un
nouveau personnage explique dans ce
round 6 est vendu si fier parce qu'ils
ont mis dans une vente d'art
contemporain
entre bastia et louise bourgeois et puis
comme il a été tellement robe en appel à
des siennes philamy ressemble à un truc
d'art contemporain et puis léonard de
vinci c'est quand même le seul peintre
qui trouve grâce aux yeux de du monde
aujourd'hui puisque c'est le seul nom
qu'on a retenue
c'était pas aussi haut que tout le monde
ait oublié puis au delà premier
s'intéresse plus trop alors que léonard
c'est le pain de des peintres c'est le
biopic avec dicaprio qui va peut-être
sortir un jour
nettoyez pas qu'il est un peu surestimé
léonard de vinci soyaux note
j'aime beaucoup ses carnets j'ai vu les
faits ce que tout le monde et les fait
tous les carnets à l'époque oui c'est un
nom il y avait des trucs en fait non non
j'ai quand même beaucoup d'affection
pour lui papa pour le salvator mundi
mais pour
les mener les machines en général mais
ils n'ont pas marché et ne marchait pas
les machines non non mais mais il ya
plein d'offres qui est quand même le
jean baptiste il est très très beau oui
oui donc il ya des des très très beau
c'est juin et mai alors ce qui est drôle
c'est que là on voit comment on peut
faire naître un peintre et un caravage
on l'a fait naître de la même manière à
un moment un grand historien italien a
fait naître caravage 400 ans après sa
mort hélas ses 500 ans après la mort de
ce peintre inconnu on peut le faire
naître tout à coup et là on se sert des
réseaux sociaux et les réseaux sociaux
vont jouer un rôle dans votre roman va
pas dévoiler tout ce qui se passe mais
mais voilà on assiste à la naissance
d'un peintre et tout le monde le monde
entier commence à se passionner pour ce
peintre que personne ne connaissait
trois semaines avant personne n'avait
jamais eu connaissance et évidemment
aussi bien commissaire priseur que votre
jeune experte en art deviennent des
stars parce que ils ont découvert à
battre de j'ai dit voilà c'est
exactement ça mais je pense que ça peut
arriver caravage c'est arrivé quand au
long du xxème siècle et ça peut arriver
de demain puisque il ya des peintres des
primitifs italiens totalement inconnu
méconnu il suffit tout à coup d'en
trouver 3 ou 4 ou d'avoir une bonne idée
et
expansion on se dit que ça pourrait
marcher mais c'est ça qui m'a intéressé
c'est c'est raconter comment on fabrique
un mythe dans peinture comment un
tableau devient un tableau de musées que
tout le monde a envie de photographier
d'aller voir
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'un tableau
raconte en dehors du factice qui soit
beau jeu c'est vrai pour les paysages
aussi il ya des paysages qui tout à coup
apparaît sur instagram et qui dans les
semaines et les mois qui n attirent des
milliers des dizaines de milliers de
gens à tel point qu'on oblige les fermes
et de fermer l'endroit pour que les gens
arrêtent de le saccager au fond on fait
naître des peintres comme on fait naître
des paysages comme toujours existé mais
tout à coup ils sont sur instagram c'est
plus tout à fait la même chose et il ya
tout le truc aussi du peintre maudit et
ça attire beaucoup les gens forcément ma
le caravage toute son histoire ça
participe de sa légende et de la
mythification c'est à dire quand on
retrouve des moments de sa vie qui font
que on a envie d'en savoir plus il est
mystérieux il est c'est dans le cadre
caravage c'est particulier lui et comme
il a été condamné à mort il est
tous les jours mais van gogh peintre
maudit enfin ce genre hey ça marche très
bien
il ya une morale dans votre livre
quelqu'un dit plus on dénonce plus vous
m puis vous à bâle et qui ici d'ailleurs
aussi bien marcel duchamp que que bansky
de banque sib plus on dénonce plus vous
aime plus que vous avez oui bah ça
c'était par rapport
à l'oeuvre de banksy qui s'est vendue
aux enchères en fait j'en sais pas si
vous avez suivi il ya une oeuvre qu'on a
achetée aux enchères et puis en fait il
y avait une machine à découper le papier
à l'intérieur et s'est autodétruite
voilà c'est un coup de com mais est en
même temps c'est aussi une dénonciation
de l'absurdité du
de l'enchère et et andy ses morceaux de
papier et phare sur le sol va demain ils
vendront trois fois plus cher que l'or
originale parce que barcella marchand
c'est la même chose il ya beaucoup
d'ironie c'est une critique du système
au départ en tout cas série du med le
système la bella va devenir un objet de
musée avec une barrière au tour alors
que soutient
le roman s'appelle le grand art il est
signé les à simone et alegria et il est
paru chez flammarion
[Musique]